i was taking home about twenty thousand  dollars a month for my gym and i was  still sleeping on the floor and here's  why i actually very security driven i  wanted to make sure that i had a nest  egg which i had pretty much blown in  order to start this business and so  every month all i wanted to do was make  sure that i covered the rent of the  business and then i had no employees at  the time for the first few months and so  i did everything in the business so  everything above the rent was mine to  keep and so every month as it went up my  profit went up but i just allowed that  all into savings because i was so  worried about something potentially  happening and ultimately i think it was  the right call because i was able to  make bigger decisions later because of  the savings i was able to have by not  getting a place and spending stuff on  furnishing and all that kind of jazz